I am seriously going to suggest that you
first watch or listen to this segment
before letting children hear it because
it's that disturbing I I'm just putting
it out there I want to tell you I'm
about to play a clip that is
extraordinarily disturbing this might be
the most disturbing Christian sex story
of all time this was Unearthed by uh
hemant meta who writes the friendly
atheist sub stack he's really good I
follow him on Twitter okay I am going to
play a video for you here
where Dr Glenn Hill and his wife Phyllis
Hill
uh were interviewed by pro-abstinence
girl defined co-host Bethany Beale
in this interview okay I I so I'm sorry
that we I just have to explain it in
this way there aren't there almost
aren't words enough to describe what
happens here
um
the wife of the couple
Miss Hill
describes that for a long time
she believed she had no clitoris
and she oh my God she only found out
specifically what it is
when her friend showed her on her baby
girl
I've never seen anything like this okay
look look at this
like I was like yeah I'm broken like I
didn't even think that that was a weird
sentence but she said okay what can you
define broken what what are you saying
what does that mean and and then I just
said oh well I don't have a clitoris
um because at this point Glenn had read
enough to know that a clitoris was
involved and uh yeah didn't know where
he was as clueless as I was but once he
accidentally stumbled upon an issue of
the New England medical journal and was
but knew that that mattered and that had
to do with an orgasm and it's like yeah
I've never orgasmed and there's no
pleasure I don't enjoy it matter of fact
I hate it wow I just endure it we just
get through it as fast as possible and
um
and so yeah we shared that openly and
she was in the medical field
and uh she was like okay well
what do you mean you don't have a
clitoris and our friend
after a bit said you know I I just feel
like taking fillers in the back room and
showing her what I'm talking about well
Phillis started to stand up uh and then
this other woman said but I just can't I
can't do that
our oldest child had been born uh which
is a little girl and eventually uh a
fellows was changing uh our daughter's
diaper and uh our friend showed her on
um our little girl you know where the
clues is located which is huge
information for films and again it's
stunning to me
I that's pretty darn basic folks I
this is the moral majority right or
something like that this is I mean
cringe doesn't cover it this this is
just
I'm struggling to find the words in
maybe a different language would better
have the words for this but I'm
struggling to find the words to explain
and understand
this bizarre turn
now this video since him and found it
it was set to private
and it looks like they're trying to kind
of scrub this because this is so
completely insane now Glenn Hill
is a quote clinical sexologist
that's what he describes himself as
apparently with a PhD
how do these things happen what is
happening here where the people
least able
to actually
work through and understand and explain
also I mean listen to sexual dysfunction
and of lack of uh sex said all these
different things you know
um
and these are the folks that say we are
the ones who can explain to you
uh the right how things work and the
right way this it's borderline you
should just check in with child
protective services and clearly they
recognize that they're trying to scrub
this video it it has just it has creepy
all over it it is creepy all over it and
you don't have to think that anything
inappropriate was going on with a baby
to just see this and go oh that it's
just I'm cringing it just doesn't feel
right what's going on here uh and they
are now doing everything they can to
make sure that this stuff is all removed
we may get hit with some kind of
copyright violation for even surfacing
this I'll keep you posted if indeed that
happens but uh really really vile stuff
quick break back after this are you
tired of using words like very all the
time very good very busy very tired
words can get monotonous and if you're a
non-native English speaker who finds it
tough to learn new words and remember
them and use them in the right way in
context maybe you just need to change
your learning approach I am a non-native
English speaker I learned English very
young but when I moved to the United
States from Argentina at the time
speaking only Spanish and the right
approach to learning new words is really
useful for communicating in any context
you should look into a book by Michael
cavallaro called the Epp method three
super simple steps to build and retain
essential vocabulary for adults they're
sponsoring Today's Show and you can find
it at MPC author.com this book will help
you improve your English vocabulary
tremendously even potentially improve
verbal scores on standardized tests it's
full of retention exercises words
arranged by themes examples in context
antonyms synonyms my favorite chapter is
called an exploration of death which has
words like lurid martyred Macabre it's
how you learn new words quickly but also
retain them for longer and the book is
fantastic even if you are a native
English speaker start growing your
vocabulary by picking up a copy of the
Epp method go to MPC author.com the link
is down below